this exhibition is multiple occupancy
Eleanor Anton selves here at the Wallach
art gallery at Columbia University
Eleanor Anton is an extremely important
conceptual artist working since the 60s
in photography video film performance
writing painting sculpting drawing many
media and this is the first time that
her major selves or characters that
she's inhabited over say the past 30
years have been brought together in one
exhibition in a homecoming here in New
York one of the reasons that I wanted to
organize multiple occupancy Eleanor
Anton cells around this body of work is
that I think in particular at this
moment a lot of artists are looking back
to the issues that are at the core of
the cells namely plays with history
archival slippage transformation
destabilizing identity I think that
those issues are at the core of the work
of some of the most interesting young
and emerging artists of our time at the
core of ourselves is also this idea or
this question what happens when you
present one way and identify differently
and I think that that that question is
pervasive throughout the work in this
show but that's a question that
resonates for so many different kinds of
people and has been taken up and recast
and reinterpreted again and again and
again I very much enjoyed working with
Emily liebert my curator but I was
actually a little nervous because um
I've all the years I've worked this is a
body of the work and I didn't know how
by itself it would look but when I
thought I was really and truly delighted
with the way it looked I think it's very
very beautiful it's clear you can follow
a kind of trajectory between the selves
I think you did a cool job of recreating
aunt anovas set from
recollections of my life with Z aguila
in terms of which pieces to choose we
wanted to it required thinking about who
the characters are at their sm for
example choosing a work that's called
cottony act from the first room we see
her first female self the ballerina and
the ballerina has mastered the art of
the pose but she can't dance in motion
and this piece caught in the act of 1973
exposes that and this really sort of
funny and and also moving sort of sad
way we have these photographs that show
the ballerina holding her pose very
elegantly and then it's accompanied by a
video which reveals that in order to
take those photographs the ballerina
need somebody to hand her a stick she
holds the stick when and then when she
gets her balance she lets go of the
stick the photographer shoots the
photograph and then she falls down so
the video you know in a sense catches
the ballerina in the act so that really
highlights the sort of you know the sort
of patheticness in a sense of this
ballerina so there is a lot of comedy a
lot of pathos and a lot of dealing with
political and social issues and
aesthetic issues of you know of the
times i live in the wallet prides itself
on being able to make new and exciting
publications for the projects that they
work on in this case we're able to do a
very interesting new publication adding
to the discourse on Eleanor antenna
including a hilarious interview with
Emily and Eleanor we were also able with
this exhibition to do extremely exciting
live public programming with our partner
at school of the arts here at columbia
university but also around performa the
performance art festival we were able to
have eleanor perform and also be in
conversation with other younger artists
who look very much to her work today